- Les exercices militaires
chinois du mois dernier ont fait
craindre à une invasion de
Taïwan. Le ministre des A
étrangères de Taïwan considère
qu'il s'agissait d'une pratique
en vue d'isoler l'île et
d'imposer un blocus pour forcer
la réunification avec la Chine.
(coups de feu)
Taipei siet depuis
l'invasion russe en Ukraine.
"La Chine est plus puissante et
plus influente que la Russie
croit le ministre Wu.
Plusieurs pays d'Asie et
d'Amérique latine sont prêts
à se tourner vers
le modèle chinois.
Un appel entendu.
Les politiciens étrangers
se succèdent à Taïwan.
Une délégation canadienne
envisage de s'y rendre
le mois prochain.
Le premier ministre Trudeau
invite cependant les élus
dérer les conséquences
d'une telle visite.
Réaction dénoncée par certains
comme une forme de soumission
à la Chine, mais pas par
le gouvernement taïwanais.
Le ministre Wu espère que
les liens d'affaires avec
le Canada se développeront
davantage prochainement.
En juin dernier, Ottawa
a annoncé la création du Comitéé
de formuler des recommandations
au gouvernement. La stratégie
canadienne pour contrer
l'influence de la Chine
dans la région risque cependant
de ne pas voir le jour
avant l'an prochain.
Ici Philippe Leblanc,
Radio-Canada, Tai